hi it's Matthew Barnett details and we
just finished the Paris collection there
are a lot of interesting and cool trends
coming your way for fall/winter 2012-13
one of the most prevalent times this
season was proportion mixing clothing
was either boxy or oversized on top
paired to the skinny or slim trouser or
it was slimmer on the top clothes crop
with a wider leg trouser pant we saw
these oversized proportions on top
especially at rap Stemmons that had
those boxy coats make sure they're
really slim skinny shorts and again
along that that had the sloping shoulder
jackets mix with a really tailored
skinny trousers there was a feeling of
tough elegance of the collections a lot
of the shows had pieces that were very
masculine and cut but the fabrics were
really luxurious and rich we saw a lot
of high waisted pants on the runway and
this is a new and interesting silhouette
this is absolutely something you should
get into football winter every
collection has some piece of sportswear
it mixed in with the tailored pieces and
this is definitely something you want to
do you can see there's a Louie Vuitton
with those silver nylon jackets mixed
with all the tailored trousers and shoes
and we also saw this a long bow where
the tougher was mixed with the trench
coat and another favorite with a muted
color trainers approximate these were
the easiest way to make sportswear into
your work there are a lot of puffer
jackets out on the runway some were more
exaggerated and fast and forward and
then others were more classic in
students there's a puffer out there for
everyone you have a lot to choose from
thanks so much following this this
season we'll see you next time